ce soir je vais europe et reda alors tué
[Musique]
alors que
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
quoi
samir
merci patrick d'être avec nous ce soir
boris et moi on est comme des fous ouais
moi aussi tu sais je suis un mec de nuit
alors j'ai joué toute la nuit ça fait un
bien fou [ __ ] tu nous regardes toute
la nuit je regarde tout le temps la nuit
rentrant attention de dire que tu dors
avec moi toutes les nuits je dors avec
toi toutes les nations en accord avec
toi tu es cela dit la femme derrière
bande pas beaucoup au bon accueil en
battant patrick sébastien cabinet
[Applaudissements]
trois tailles ne le faisait pas la fine
bouche au mali
c'est génial robichaud voici comment on
va pouvoir social et qu il se passe des
choses
dès ce soir
[Applaudissements]
la testa
bonnel micro ma patrie allez-y et
attention c'est parti on va chanter la
fiesta
ce soir je leur offre
[Musique]
on y va vous avez tous une question il
faut répondre sanglots vous êtes tous
préparent une question ici je sais même
pas de quoi vous avez parlé vous avez
souvent dit avoir fréquenté beaucoup les
boîtes échangistes
c'était la réaction des gens et vous
reconnaissez ces jeux
[Applaudissements]
les rotations et maxime je vais pas te
les imiter euros qu'est ce qu'on est
bien non il n'y a pas de réaction
particulière se tue c'est là dedans il
faut que tu connais
[Applaudissements]
il fait chaud
non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ok ça
[Applaudissements]
n'est ce pas
pas d'imagés
[Musique]
c'est la tonne
mais c'est bon
[Musique]